if you thought you were destined to find
a mythical treasure what would you do
you'll be forced to team up with a
ragtag crew to fight brutal soldiers
vicious Pirates and mutated clowns and
you'll need to find a boat to even have
a chance of finding the one-piece
treasure I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the East blue quadrant in one
piece part one This Crew is going to
risk their lives in order to find the
most valuable treasure in the world
Luffy hears a wannabe pirate with an
insane power and is on a stupid quest to
find the most valuable thing in this
world the one piece treasure and become
king of the Pirates sailing on this boat
he desperately tries to recruit this
random seagull to join his crew but his
persuasion skills suck and that's when
the boat suddenly starts sinking unable
to swim he quickly hops into this Empty
Barrel because nothing will stop him
quickly falling asleep inside can only
comes across the battle between innocent
Sailors and one of the most horrifying
Pirates of all time a pirate that we all
know weebs Captain alvida Unleash Your
anime Obsession on metal canvases oh I'm
so excited experience the magic of anime
like never before with this plate this
plate is the future of hassle-free
posters and their 21st century metal art
brings your favorite anime scenes to
life capturing every detail in HD
Brilliance they're so freaking good that
you'll forget that you don't actually
have a taxidermied Opera trapped on your
wall the sturdy metal construction
ensures that your beloved characters and
scenes are displayed with the utmost
Clarity and vibrancy and you'll have
designs from over 40 000 artists to
choose from so pick from disc plates 1.3
million licensed designs and lay your
eyes on your next great anime roommate
little cutely or creepily Stout you
securely from your wall thanks to
displaced magnet mounted system allowing
you to snap the metal poster onto
anywhere you see fit anime heroes face
countless challenges and so does your
wall art I'm not kidding that's why
displaced metal posters are built to
withstand a lifetime of intense staring
just like those epic anime battles no
fading no warping your post will remain
as captivating as the day you first put
them up I had some come through and boy
do I love them oh so freaking much httpa
gives 20 off when buying one to two disc
plays and 30 off when buying three or
more thanks again to displate for
sponsoring this video finally we're
doing something about one piece gosh I'm
so excited if I was one of these
innocent Merchant ships I would destroy
this Pirate Ship by taking advantage of
their psychology and the vital
architecture flaw that all ships have
yes I'll be talking in a piratey voice
throughout the entire episode you're
welcome these idiots are up against a
famous pirate known as Captain alvida on
her boat known as the Miss love duck
alvida shape here looks like it's a
Dutch flute judging from the pear-shaped
Stone known for its wide flat bottom
allowing tons of treasure to be carried
and a highly customizable layout unlike
this innocent merchant ship it makes
sense why they chose this ship because
it's badass and can have a great
powerful offense however this shape here
on the left was actually the more
preferred vessel for pirates during the
Golden Age of piracy due to its
lightweight nature which also allowed
them to all of their preferred method of
Blitz Warfare these types of smaller
boats gave Pirates a better chance to
surprise their enemies last minute by
making a huge frightening shot Force
forcing the enemy to surrender before
the battle even began however though
these guys don't have that luxury since
there was no land nearby it's likely
they were chased by Oviedo ship until
this point and then decided to turn and
fight her broadside to broadside for no
reason which is interesting because this
ship was made for stealth purposes
broadside to broadside fighting is when
all the guns on one side of the ship are
fired at once at another however if I
was them in the shitty ship of a
situation I would focus on the natural
weak points that almost all ships have
Canada like these in generals are very
inaccurate this is why broadside
broadside fighting was so common because
you literally had to get up super close
in order to have a more precise shot
however using our ship's superior
mobility i instead would have opted to
cut across This ship's bow the front or
Stern the back as the areas of this part
of the ships is almost impossible to set
up cannons in without a ship being
designed for Speed we could easily sail
Behind these points before attacking
from these angles the back part of the
ships is the most vulnerable disabling
them enough so they won't be able to
catch us means I will be able to get
away we are the faster vessel and we
also have to remember that pirates don't
like to sink ships because then you
can't steal from them and this means
that even during the battle itself they
would be way more hesitant of trying to
fire to our ship because of this reason
we have what they want we would be able
to beat this situation by taking
advantage of their blind spots and
utilizing the lighter ship's speed the
Pirates quickly win the battle and begin
collecting all the riches from the ship
including Luffy from the sea later this
kid named Kobe wait no no not that Kobe
anyways this Twitchy kid cleans the
pirate's bloody weapons and that's when
you hear some noise coming from one of
the barrels he goes to check it out and
that's when Luffy pops out from his nap
he tells Kobe that he is a pirate but
he's a good kind of pirate and he's on a
mission to find the one-piece treasure
and he's headed to the Grand line to
find it Colby gets shocked and tells
Luffy that the grand line is known as
the pirate graveyard filled with
bloodthirsty land and and sea monsters
and thousands of pirates he will never
make it out of their alive and Kobe says
he's nuts and he needs to leave the ship
before the Pirates wake up snaking him
out on the dock they head to the
lifeboats and that's when Luffy
accidentally hits his paddle on this
Bell waking up all the Pirates including
Captain alvida they quickly get
surrounded by everyone albeda thinks
Kobe was trying to escape he tries to
reason with her but Luffy says that he
doesn't have to take orders from a mean
person like her pissing her off
instantly she tries to hit Luffy but he
Dodges her attack and then this guy but
Luffy's body bounces the bullet back out
stunning everybody as Luffy reveals his
powers his body is made of pure rubber
Captain alvita tries to attack it but
Luffy slips her attack making her
destroy her ship's steering wheel and
causes the ship to catch on fire pissing
her off even more alvita tries to take
it out on Kobe movie tries to save his
life and uses his signature gum gum
pistol move blowing her away and making
the other Pirates back off he then tells
Kobe to come with him and they escape on
the Lifeboat the next day Kobe finds out
from Luffy that he doesn't actually know
where the ground line is making him
realize that they are lost Luffy says
that hey they just need to find a map to
help them get there then everything will
be all right Kobe tries not to panic and
Luffy tries to calm him down he asks him
what his dream in life is and Kobe says
he wants to become a Marie but he'll
never be able to achieve it so Luffy
then slaps him and says that if that is
his dream then he must never give up and
he'll help him achieve it they set a
course for the closest Marine base and
Luffy says there he'll sneak in to get a
map to the Grand line and continue on
his journey and also Kobe can sign up to
join the Marines Kobe thinks they just
can't sneak into a military base but
Luffy says trust him later they reach
this base getting Munch Louis thinks
about how to sneak in and steal a map
but that's when they see a fight Break
Out nearby and Luffy watches one of the
fighters protect this little girl and
fights these marines seeing all the
fancy sword moves he does Luffy sees
this green head guy who thinks that he's
never seen before taking out all three
of these marines down with ease he then
notices also this orange haired girl in
the corner dragged this unconscious
Marine away I wonder who that is
meanwhile though green hair guy
interrogates the leader of this group
scared as hell the guy tries to calm him
down and says that his name is helmeppo
and that his father runs this Marine
base and he can give him anything he
wants green hair guy says that his name
is Zorro and he wants to collect his
Bounty for all the pirates that he's
killed so far hell Maple then takes him
to go meet his father Captain Morgan no
not the drink he tells zaro that he can
elect his Bounty but he was spend a week
in jail for first assaulting multiple
Marines Zorro says that he will cut off
the handoff anybody who tries to touch
him impressing Captain Morgan who offers
him a job to join the Marines because
he's got serious skill and is useful
unlike his useless son but zaharu says
Nah pissing him off causing Captain
Morgan to put Zorro in jail later that
night outside Luffy talks to Kobe about
uzoro he wants to recruit him into his
pirate crew as soon as possible and he
tells Cobra he's now figured out a plan
on how to steal the map and he tells
Kobe to go get the boat ready tomorrow
while he gets ready to sneak into the
base okay the journey to the Grand line
means that these guys need to start
focusing on finding a badass crew over a
badass boat this is why I would use an
extroversion index assignment used to
screen for fighter pilots in order to
find out new crew members let me explain
the journey to the Grand line means that
they'll need more than just a badass
crew the grand line is a stretch of sea
east to west around the planet known as
the most dangerous place on Earth and
the big part is because of the weather
it's unpredictable and dangerous and the
wildlife is much more lethal in the
water and also on the islands around it
and this means that we need a stronger
crew in order to be able to have a
better chat and sailing through the
Grand line since the standard rules of
meteorology whether to apply this means
that the General Ocean patterns around
this area are extremely volatile and
this means that we can expect all types
of to try and kill us water spout
storms blizzards heat waves thick fogs
Cyclones appearing quickly and
impossible to predict even around the
surrounding Islands which have their own
distinct climate all going on at
different times and in a way this
journey will require our members to have
qualities similar to what fighter pilots
must have since their job is one of the
most stressful jobs in the world where
Split Second Life or Death decisions
must be regularly made so what I will do
would be to go to the first town bar and
look for recruits because we need a crew
and then we'll have an easier time
snooping around and figure out their
past and they're hammered we need to
make them stay loyal to us and not screw
us over on the journey to the grounded
line I would get ready to bribe them
with some ethical not so ethical types
of spoils the next day Luffy sneaks into
this sewer drain and accidentally runs
into Zorro tied up Luffy tells him that
he's impressed by his moves and wants
him to join his pirate crew but zaro
says he kills pirates for a living so
Luffy then unties him for no reason and
says that life is more than just killing
it's about friendship and inventure and
all that blah blah blah blah then he
leaves him to continue on with his
mission heading down into this Cellar
Luffy comes across this thief posing as
a marine confronting her he finds out
that her name is Nami and he tells her
that he recognizes her from the bar and
says that they are both looking for the
map to the Grand line he walks past and
says that he thinks the map is in the
captain's office and that's when they
run into the captain himself Captain
Morgan Nami quickly improvises and tells
the captain that she is taking this
prisoner to jail trigging him into
letting them pass and then she reveals
to Luffy that she just stole the
captain's Keys impressed Louis then asks
her to join his pirate crew but she says
ill reaching the office they quickly
start looking around for the map finding
this hidden safe now he works to crack
it open but that's when the bass alarm
sounds off and Nami tells Luffy that the
guards that she knocked out in the
cellar have now been just discovered
does nobody bother to hide the bodies
that they knock out jeez Luffy then
speeds up the process and wraps his
stretchy fingers around the safe and
then he manages to pull the safe and
them right out the window Landing in the
courtyard and they quickly get
surrounded by guards but Luffy quickly
finds out that Nami also has some sick
moves and that's when Zorro passes by
them on his way out of the castle but
stops and decides to help Luffy out
joining the fight they all tag team
Captain Morgan then finally shows up
pissed off as hell Zara and Luffy try to
attack him but he easily overpowers them
thinking quickly they realize that they
need to work together and quickly figure
out a system of attack going high and
low Charlo then uses his famous three
sword technique to push Captain Morgan
back while Luffy combos with his gum gum
with moo knocking Captain Morgan out
once super raw sorrow then helps carry
the safe out andami says that she has a
boat that they can use to get away
reaching the docks they get stopped by
his certain Captain Morgan's son helmepo
and he holds them a gun point about to
kill them he quickly gets knocked out by
Luffy's friend Twitchy boy Kobe at the
last minute escorting them to the docks
Kobe then tells Luffy that he's going to
stay on this island to try and fulfill
his dream of becoming a Marine and he
tells them that next time they might be
enemies but he thanks Luffy for
everything and the two wave goodbye and
Luffy's new crew sails off later that
night Nami then finally manages to open
a safe they find a map that will lead
them to the ground line but Luffy then
realizes that da he he doesn't know how
to read forcing Nami to become his
Navigator and she reads the map and
tells them where and what the grand line
really is the grand line is a
treacherous stretch of ocean area that
is full of bigger islands bigger cities
and much more dangerous Pirates and
monsters that they will encounter Luffy
fills Zorro in about the one piece but
Nami tells him that he's just a myth
they notice a red flare outside and go
to check it out and then they start
collapsing and Luffy realizes that
someone dangerous is coming for them
acting quick he swallow and he catches a
glimpse of the ship headed straight for
them eventually passing out a while
later they finally wake up and realized
that they've been taken hostage Luffy
tells Nami that he put the map in a safe
place and reveals that he thinks that
they've been kidnapped by other Pirates
but he can talk his way out of this
situation because he's such a good
communicator the Box suddenly opens up
and they discover that they are inside
of a circus full of audience members
trapped as prisoners it's strange this
clown enters and the movie recognizes
his face and says that he saw his wanted
poster at the Marine base the clown
introduces himself as buggy the clown
and tells Luffy that him and his friends
are in big big trouble because you see
his crew have been planning to rob the
Marine base to steal the map for months
before Luffy got to it first so he had
dips now Luffy must hand over the map or
else and then Luffy says that he will
become king of the Pirates making
everybody around them laugh Zorro then
threatens buggy to let them go but to
Nami offers this clown a trait and she
tells buggy that their crew has a unique
person in their group and that buggy can
have him if he lets them go she then
grabs Louis Lee's precious hat and
throws it up into the air forcing Luffy
to use his stretchy powers to reach for
it and buggy sees what Luffy really is
but in doing so allows Nami to escape
the area running outside she sees the
whole town around her destroyed and is
horrified wow apparently she has a heart
clearly she must be traumatized by
something buggies minions quickly catch
her and drag her back inside of this
circus and buggy tells them that he
overheard Louie saying that he has
hidden the map to the ground line
somewhere and he will torture all of
them until he finds out where it is and
he splits up Zoro and Nami from Luffy
and he says he has a special present for
this stretchy kid quickly tying him up
he orders his crew to stretch him until
his body breaks but Luffy resists
telling him anything and that's when
buggy comes up with an idea he tells
Luffy that no one ever wants to be a
pirate unless they're trying to impress
someone noticing Luffy strange hat that
he now recognizes and he says that he
knew a man who used to wear a hat just
like this as a matter of fact he's
certain that that hat is that man's hat
somebody that Luffy grew up with maybe
basically his daddy a man called
red-haired Shanks Luffy gets shocked and
finds out that buggy used to serve with
his father figure in the Navy when they
were both younger and they both became
Pirates but claims that Shanks betrayed
him for some reason now pissed off more
than ever he orders his servant to
stretch Luffy even further but the man
gets too scared and refuses his order at
the end of his rope buggy walks over to
his audience and threatens to kill this
innocent kid and seeing this Luffy gets
angry and uses his powers to break free
and quickly fires his gum gum pistol
shooting Buggy's head clean off and
thinks that he's now saved the day but
that was his biggest mistake Buggy's
body continues to keep on standing and
Luffy realizes that he also has powers
just like him buggy tells Luffy years
ago he ate a magical fruit The Chop Chop
fruit and now he has the power to split
up his entire body and that's when his
hand shows up from behind Luffy and
knocks him out meanwhile Nami and Zoro
work on Breaking Free inside of this
room and that's when one of Bucky's crew
members then enters and claims that
Zorro killed and chopped off the head of
of his pirate brother and he says that
his name is Kabachi and will now make
Zorro suffer for his actions he then
spins him around and starts using him as
target practice allowing Nami to quickly
brute force her locks free she goes up
behind kabaji and knocks him out letting
them run off but back outside Luffy then
finally wakes up inside of this box full
of his one weakness salt water buggy
tells him that he knows that saltwater
is the only thing that can take away
both of their powers and now Luffy will
drown if he doesn't talk barely able to
stand he tells buggy that his crew will
come to rescue him buggy laughs long and
hard and prepares to watch Luffy drown
but that's when Zorro and Nami busted
and quickly smash Luffy's cage freeing
him Luffy gasps for Aaron accidentally
he threw up the map and that's when
buggy runs to grab it and Nami and Zoro
face off against him and zaro tells him
they have him cornered and he tries to
attack him but that's when they realized
what they're really up against buggy the
clown and he activates his full powers
and splits his body apart cornering
these two he easily knocks them back off
their feet but that's when Luffy finally
recovers and he gets up but buggy
deploys his chop chop Cannon move
knocking Luffy back alright this is
crazy but if I was them I would defeat a
buggy by using the one biological
weakness that him you and me and every
other person on Earth has let me explain
buggy hears like Luffy except he ate the
power about our Nomi devil fruit which
means that he has the power to split his
body into multiple pieces and is immune
from slashing attacks however unlike
Luffy hasn't trained to utilize the
powers completely and this is how we
take him down while he might be strong
yes he's just like everybody else here
and still relies on basic biology and
it's noted that in order to move his
body parts he needs to see where they
are in order to control them which means
he uses his eyes in order to maintain
balance humans require coordinated
efforts of three different body systems
the eyes the inner ear and the sensors
in the body's muscular system using
these three the brain is able to
determine the body's position and
deploys the strategies it needs to use
in order to help the body maintain
balance see what I'm saying my weebs is
that most people rely on their eyes
first over anything else which means we
need to come up from behind him and put
a blindfold on him or by finding some
alcohol and temporarily blinding him
because this will give us a few moments
to try and capture all his body parts in
a bag of some kind rendering him useless
and then from here we can just Club him
to death like a baby seal and then we'll
be be able to escape while he works on
getting his vision back knowing they
can't beat him with head-on attacks he
thinks fast and calls out tanami to open
those crates in the back and then Luffy
starts timing Buggy's attacks eventually
hitting Buggy's body parts straight back
into nami's crates locking each one they
quickly Force buggy to run out of body
parts to use making him helpless Louis
then activates his gum gum puzzle
and blows buggy far away saving the day
he hands the map back to Nami shocking
her since well she betrayed him and he
tells her that she is their Navigator
after all and then they free all of
Buggy's prisoners allowing them to be
done with this side quest and then the
three head back out to sea and continue
on with their Journey to the Grand line
on the way there Nami goes into the
Ship's Cabin for some privacy but that's
when she secretly opens this hidden door
using this device she calls somebody and
tells them that she has the map if he
always later Zorro tells Nami that they
now have a huge problem the boat has a
hole and is now leaking rushing in to
check the damage she realizes that her
secret snail phone thing has been
destroyed on when she argues with Zara
for not telling her about the problem
sooner and now the group realizes that
they need a new boat in order to make it
to the Grand lie coming up with a
solution Nami says that they should head
to a place called the gecko Island since
it is the closest island to their
location later the group reaches the
gecko Island and Nami tells them to
start looking around for a new ride she
warned them though that since they don't
have any money to buy a ship they will
have to steal one but again Luffy is not
about that Thug Life tells them that
they must get a ship the right way and
these two don't think that's possible
and Luffy says that he will find them a
free ship looking around Luffy then
suddenly spots the most tantalizingly
sexiest piece of woods that he's ever
seen in his life heading to this boat he
meets this one guy named usop who tells
him all about the ship bragging is the
fastest water Beast that he'll ever ride
in his life excited Luffy tells him that
he wants to have this boat without
paying any money and without providing
anything in return for it so usop looks
at him like he's nuts and says that the
boat isn't for sale that he doesn't even
own it Zorro and The Nami show up and
Luffy excitedly tells them that they
must get this boat and find out from
usop that he is close friends with the
owner of this ship a rich girl named
Kaya and he says that they could make a
deal with her so he takes them to go see
her after walking for a bit they finally
reached Kaya's mansion and run into one
of the people working there he stops
usop and tells him that he's not welcome
here but just then Kaya calls out to him
happy to see him he says that he's come
to wish her a happy birthday and has
brought friends to come see her these
are people he just met and that's when
this suspicious looking butler named
kalador tells usable and he says that he
can't just show up without warning and
Kaya begs him to let her friends stay
for the night for her birthday dinner
reluctantly kalador agrees but tells
them that they must shower first because
they all stink later usop sneaks into
Kaya's room to use her secret entrance
and gives her his birthday gift he tells
her it's a valuable Pearl that makes up
some story about how he got it and tells
her of his adventures of the outside
world and makes her super excited but
that's when she starts violently
coughing and so he goes to get her
medicine tea and she updates him about
her health condition saying she hasn't
gotten any better but his wild stories
are keeping her happy meanwhile Luffy's
crew prepares for dinner and Zoro asks
the group if they recognize the butler
collator as he's seen his face somewhere
before but they don't Louis then thinks
that if he can convince Kaya to give
them his ship and Luffy makes a bet with
nami who doesn't believe him and if he
fails they'll do it her way and steal a
ship instead meanwhile in the kitchen
kalador checks on dinner preparations
and he tells his minions that everything
must scale perfectly tonight because
it's their last shot scaring the hell
out of these two later at dinner
everybody meets up in the main house and
Zorro tells kalador to his face that he
thinks he has seen him at a bar
somewhere before but kylador doesn't
know what he's talking about and then
this one dinner guest tries to speak to
Kai about some urgent family business
but kalador interrupts them and tells
him to not bother Kaya with work issues
on her birthday the servants then
announced that dinner is served and
everybody heads into the dining room
sitting down Kaya says she wants to try
but some of the guests are eating but
caledona tells us that she can't go off
of her super strict meal plan I could
only eat this nasty looking soup instead
and that's when Nami interrupts and
tells kalador the kai should be able to
eat whatever she wants but that's when
Luffy interrupts and asks Kai about her
ship that usop mentioned Kaya tells them
that at midnight tonight she will become
the sole owner of not just the ship but
the whole Shipyard making her even more
Filthy Rich Luffy congratulates her and
then randomly reveals that they are
pirates making us up spit out his drink
in shock he gets on the table and
announces that him and his crew are
headed to the Grand line to find the
one-piece treasure and wants Kaya's ship
in order to get there but poor poor Kaya
starts coughing at all of the confusion
and kalador gets mad at Luffy for making
her sick and he uses them to leave at
once but Kaya begs them to let them all
stay the night instead with their asses
covered for now they stay the night and
later that night one of Kaya's dinner
guests goes to confront khalidor and
tells him that he must speak with Kaya
at once about her family's Shipyard
before midnight because some of the
paperwork doesn't make sense khalidor
tries to calm him down but it doesn't
work forcing him to reveal who he really
is and that's when he dashes behind this
guy and stabs him with his five-bladed
claws brutally killing him elsewhere
Zorro bumps into Luffy and says that
he's looking for a drink hungry himself
Luffy tags along as the two try to find
the kitchen nearby Nami works on
stealing all of the valuables in the
house and that's when she suddenly hears
incoming footsteps and quickly hides in
this room nearby but in doing so she
accidentally entered Kaya's room who is
now caught her red-handed Kaya thinks
she is really a pirate but Nami gets
insulted and says that she hates Pirates
and Kaya tells her that she can have
whatever she wants since they are
friends of usop which means that they
are friends of hers Nami thinks it's sus
but quickly warms up Takaya and they
quickly make conversation about their
lives and troubles meanwhile though
sorrow and Luffy finally find the
kitchen and spot usop hanging out and he
asks them if they really are going after
the one-piece treasure and Luffy offers
him a spot on his team gosh this guy
will let anybody in but usop says that
he has to watch over Kaya and then they
make small talk and he basically reveals
that he loves Kaya without realizing her
parents mysteriously died a few years
ago and ever since then kalador has
watched over her and her parents house
and zaro thinks something is strange
about that that guy that's when Luffy
notices that usop is a great shot and he
reveals that he learned his skills from
his dad who was a pirate's named to
yasop the great stunning Luffy and he
realizes that he knows usopp's dad since
he was a part of shang's crew many years
ago and zaro then tells them that he
needs wine so usup takes him to The Wine
Cellar while Luffy stays back to finish
off this giant pot of delicious looking
soup Zoro and usapa finally reached the
cellar but that's when they discover
this corpse laying in plain sight and
it's still warm sorrow then notices that
this man has been stabbed five times
he's seen this style of murder before
and that's when kalador shows up armed
with five blades on each hand and his
minions right behind him and Zoro
finally remembers where he's seen him
before on a wanted poster he then
announces that this guy's real name is
Kuro captain of the black cat pirates
with a 16 million battery reward and
tells them he pretended to die at the
hands of the idiot ax hand Morgan so
that way he could hide out from the law
Zorro prepares for combat akuro says
that him and his plans cannot be stopped
the kid attacks him but misses and he
tries for another hit but quickly gets
knocked out by one of kuro's minions
leaving us up all alone and helpless
thinking quick he barely escapes through
this hole and the minions worry that
he'll alert the tower but Coulda says Ah
not to worry he says that boys cried
wolf all his entire life and then he
orders them to get rid of zoro's body
outside then Kerry Kaya's dead business
friend and zaro down into the dark hole
including his signature swords minutes
later he wakes up in shock and stares at
his terrifying future if he doesn't
escape this hole elsewhere usop finally
reaches the main town and tries to tell
everybody that pirates are on the island
but this one local tells usop that he's
lied too many times before and now
thinks he's only doing it to get
attention since his daddy left him years
ago No One Believes him anusob crumbles
but as when he runs into Twitchy face
Kobe again and his Marine crew who says
that they just reached the island and
are looking for a pirate Kobe tells
Usopp that he believes him and usop
tells helmetbo here that Kuro the black
cat pirate is on this island but of
course he thinks he's crazy saying that
his father the ax hand Morgan killed him
years ago and gets mad at Kuro and says
that they need to focus on finding the
straw hat pirate instead and that's when
usop recognizes the name and tells them
that the straw-hand pirate is his friend
and he can lead them to him if they
leave now meanwhile back in Kaya's room
the two girls get along and she tells
Nami that she should join her for
breakfast tomorrow and then she says
goodnight her and they just are all best
girlfriends now and that's when handing
out Nami has a change of heart and ends
up being oh so good and returns all the
items she stole at least keep one gosh a
little bit later she comes across Luffy
passed out in the kitchen and noises on
people are hurting coming and she
quickly hides in this cupboard and
overhears the minions enter and they
reveal their true plans they mentioned
that Luffy ate some of the poisonous
soup and is now dying minute by minute
and that's Zorro's body has been
disposed of outside suddenly everyone
hears a knock at the front door Kuro
enters and tells them to stay put while
he goes to check it out checking out the
front of the house he discovers the
Marines and tries to play it cool they
tell him that us up here has accused him
of being a pirate and introduces himself
as kalador Butler and says he has no
idea what they are talking about and
then they inspect his clothes and his
hands and the Marines don't see anything
piratey about him and kalador explains
that usop is sick in the head ever since
his daddy left him as a kid USA begs the
Marines to listen to him but helmet
Powers had enough and he says that they
are looking for a straw hat pirate on
this island and kalador eagerly tells
them that a person fitting that
description did raid the house earlier
and they captured him and he tells his
people to bring Luffy to the front of
the house quickly wiping off his mouth
the hand over Luffy to the Pirates
horrified that no one will believe him
usop runs off yelling that pirates have
invaded the island and the Marines take
Luffy and kalador tells them that he has
other things to do and tries to close
the door on them back in the Main
Kitchen Nami continues to wait for her
chance to strike that's when this girl
enters the kitchen and she uses this
opportunity to sneak out of the cupboard
and knocks her out cold but realizes
that the sound from the kitchen has now
been heard throughout the entire house
okay at this point we we are so screwed
the only way that I would save a sauce
by destroying literally everything here
the most chaotic pirate way possible let
me explain Kuro here has been the butler
for Kaya for three years and has been
wanting to inherit her family fortune
making him the biggest gold digger out
there but it makes no sense how Kaya
never thought to go see a doctor for
sickness but anyways Kuro hears the
leader of a horrifying crew and has
basically been undercover for three
years this makes him a legit psycho that
means that I would work on trying to
escape and get help first by being evil
as hell if I was Nami I would first get
a weapon and then get to work on
starting a fire within the kitchen
itself first avoid carrying some of the
flame into another area of the home and
would carry a big bottle of something
flammable along with me right now we
can't escape and we can't afford to
fight a cat Man Killer this means that
our best bet would be to force as much
attention onto this house as possible
from the outside Town folk people the
Marines and into force them to get out
of the house this will allow us to
escape from setting the kitchen and the
surrounding area on fire I would work on
grabbing a blanket to cover my face from
smoke I would hide out near the front of
the entrance in a small room or behind
some kind of cover and once Kuro and his
guys head out I'll wait for them to
leave the house follow them from behind
before throwing the flammable liquid
we're carrying on to Kuro lighting the
Flames nearby catch them on fire while I
run towards town for help because think
of this way sometimes you have to
sacrifice a few cows in order to make a
good steak outside everyone hears a
strange bang inside the house he
politely closes the door on the Marines
and he goes to check it out upstairs
usap ends up sneaking into Kaya's room
and tells her what's really going on and
who kalador really is but she doesn't
believe him and he begs her to listen
but she says snare and pimp slaps him
saying he should leave he tries but then
turns around and ends up not running
away from his problems for the first
time in his life and he tells her that
he will stay with her until he knows
she's safe a meanwhile Kuro reaches the
kitchen and gets told by his minions
that Nami is on the loose and has
overheard everything and that's when the
clock strikes midnight and with young
Kaya finally being 18. he tells them
that officially owned the shipyard and
once they kill her he will own her
Empire instead and they begin to lock
the entire house down trapping everyone
inside upstairs usop realizes that they
are trapped right as Nami busts in and
tells them that kalador's real name is
Kuro and that he is coming to kill her
for her Shipyard making Kyle realize
that her Butler has been poisoning her
through food for years and usop was
right and Kaya then comes up with an
idea and helped them Escape her room
using her Secret Tunnel right as Kuro
enters not seeing anyone in the war the
game keeps it moving by Kaya then coughs
and Kuro knows where they are he tries
to rip her apart through the wall but
they run away just in the nick of time
meanwhile the Marines make their way
back to their boat with Luffy and that's
when Kobe tells them that something
doesn't feel right about kalador but
they think he's just being crazy and
Luffy then wakes up and throws up all
the poison out making him finally useful
once again Zorro finally wakes up and
then he thinks about his epic backstory
about losing his best friend the drove
him to become the best swordsman blah
blah not important moving on he finally
gains enough balls I'm up and out of
this wow and finally Escape nearby Luffy
tries to tell Kobe that he needs to go
save his friends first Jacoby says that
he has orders right as Zoro reaches them
and easily knocks out most of the
Marines freeing Luffy he tells Kobe that
he must go save his friends and leaves
him entering back into the Mansion they
split up back inside the Ali and the
Gang reach this control room and tried
to disable the house security measures
alerting Kuro to their location Nami
then hears Kuro coming from down the
hall and quickly tells the group to hide
he then walks in and makes the classic
bad guy speech telling them he will kill
them all and then Kaya is weak and blah
blah blah is non-board Kaya takes a
weapon and gets ready to attack Kuro
even though Nami begs her not to the two
run out from cover akuro easily catches
them off guard and gets ready to kill
them both right here and the Noose up on
the back fires a slingshot right at Kuro
but he catches it rushing at him he
knocks Usopp out just outside Zara runs
into both minions and he takes them both
out at the same time charging every move
and combo they throw at him while he
dances with his blades and then he goes
to find Nami and the rest of the squad
back in the control room Kuro tries to
kill Kaya but he finally gets stopped by
Luffy who reaches them just in time he
tries to duel Kuro but figures out his
true powers and Kuro then tries to break
Luffy with psychological warfare telling
him that being a pirate means always
having to watch your back from the law
and your friends but Luffy says that
being a pirate is about Adventure and
freedom and anyone who gives up on their
dreams doesn't deserve to call
themselves a pirate including Kuro okay
we're in a sticky situation but at this
point I would kill her Enemy by
leveraging his physiology against him
I'm talking about Luffy Luffy here may
be a stand-up guy by the moment I see
some adult using cat claws as a Bonafide
weapons I really gotta root for because
kuro's tactics here are dog he's
the definition of a grade a monologue
villain who Ducks around too much from
the beginning even the moment when the
clock striked midnight he walked through
the whole mansion on his way to kill
Kaya in her room when he could have just
used his super speed to rate her in 10
seconds to get the job done and call it
a day if I was him I would have first
taken the fight in a less enclosed area
against Luffy because of our choice of
weapons and speed means that we would do
better invite him open space or even
outside especially when you consider
that we can't run and slash only stop
and slash that means we're not really
that powerful movies ranged but direct
attacks means that is method of fighting
favors this environment more I would
have used our super speed to head to the
kitchen and bring me a bag of tower
using this to throw into lofi's face and
he will likely react and destroy the
flower bag causing the flower to get
flown into the air making it harder to
breathe and see using that distraction
is what I will use to then sneak up from
behind and stab this rubber boy in the
back Checkmate and that's when Luffy
concentrates his hearing and sends a
flying punch to Kuro knocking him back
and pissing him off the last time all
the while azaro continues to fight
kuro's minions kicking their ass again
and then he jumps kicks and takes them
both out back in the control room Luffy
Dodges kuro's last moves as he quickly
runs out of breath and Luffy then grabs
both of his paws and uses his gum gum
Bell headbutt move knocking out of the
window and saving the day he then leads
everyone to the front meeting up with
Zoro and the rest of the bad guys they
realize they need to get the hell out of
here before the Marines come back and
Kaya offers her ship to them for free
well you look at that Luffy was right he
leads them to the dock and lets Luffy
secure his fancy new ride for the next
part of their Journey he asks Usha to
tag along with them but he says that he
needs to watch over Kaya and she says
that she doesn't need no Manic and
washed the shipyard by herself and
that's when the two get cute and awkward
for the last time together and then USA
plants a big one right on her and that's
when everyone sets hail and prepares to
head to the Grand line unaware of the
horrors and enemies new and old they
will soon face but what do you think
about the video don't forget to like
subscribe and leave a comment down below
and as always don't forget to check out
our how to be playlist